i would really love the next generation
of female innovators to
be able to ignore people who say they
can't do what they want to do
and just go for it
i'm dr debbie saunders i'm the founder
and ceo of wildlife drones and we've
developed the world's most advanced
drone radio tracking system
for over 20 years debbie has worked as
an ecologist and studied the movements
of small migratory birds frustrated with
the limitations of manually radio
tracking wildlife debbie developed her
own drone-based animal tracking
technology
as a
conservation ecologist who used to bird
watch for a job i find it quite
interesting that i'm now the head of a
tech business
i started off in the shed in my backyard
with a hacksaw and a drill to make my
first antennas
on with the guidance of an rf engineer i
was riding command line for the first
time i was
actually constructing hardware and i'd
never done that before but i just gave
it a shot
wildlife drones is now an award-winning
startup the tech is used by governments
to protect endangered species and
control invasive species
it's also used by ngos to protect
animals in the wild
and environmental consultants doing
impact assessments
when manual radio tracking by hand
typically we get a big handheld antenna
and we have a handheld receiver
you can walk for kilometers trying to
find that one animal
i can't pick up any of them from here
but the drone was picking them all up
with our technology we can track all of
those animals at the same time the drone
does all the hard work for you by flying
across those landscapes and providing
you with location data in real time
types of species that we've been
tracking include kakapo in new zealand
koalas in australia pangolins in vietnam
and feral pigs and other invasive
species in the united states
but even from the very start the journey
has had its challenges
we set up a really great project to
showcase exactly what we've been able to
achieve which was a world first which
was the tracking of of wild animals from
a drone
we launched the drone after it was 10
meters in the air it was literally
rendered useless because of interference
from some surrounding signals so i was
really devastated at that point in time
that actually was the beginning of
wildlife drones because i was like i'm
not going to start a business if i can't
address all of these weak points that we
identified
when i very first started i went and met
with local drone groups totally men
who are totally technical didn't know
the language that they were speaking and
yet here i was trying to set up a tech
business but i wasn't interested in the
tech per se i was interested in enabling
people to do wildlife research and so i
think it's really important to not feel
insecure
about your knowledge i employ people who
have that knowledge
in addition to the right team debbie
says surrounding herself with other
women in the industry is important
i just really did want to have some
female mentors
so i actually
tasked myself when i went to an
innovation networking event i was
incredibly fortunate to land next to a
lady called sylvia tullock who is an
incredibly successful businesswoman in
the tech space in clean technology
and from there i have actively
outreached to other women and
participated
in women's innovation programs
and there have been lots of lessons
learned along the way
it's okay to not know everything
as a scientist i always want evidence
and data to make decisions but often we
have to make decisions in the face of no
data
if i just keep taking steps i will get
there and as long as you make sure you
learn something when things go wrong
then you're always going to be stronger
moving forward
[Music]
you